hey everybody and welcome to a
mind-blowing wild ride with stevo i say
mind-blowing because i'm telling you
this is my new all-time favorite wild
ride with stevo episode i mean it blew
my mind i love this guy i love what we
talk about and
man i'm so excited for you to digest
me and kevin smith and what we talked
about i'm also very excited about the
fact that this is brought to you by
geology
the number one in men's
skin care with over 5 000 5 star reviews
and a great deal for the wild ride
listeners if you go to
geology.com that is g e o l o g i e
dot com and use the promo code stevo
then you're gonna get up to 70 off of
your 30-day trial now their eye creams
so epic i put it on just one side i can
just feel that side just becoming
tighter and
not wrinkly man i love their products
and so will you so let's get you on over
to
geology.com
use the promo code stevo for this epic
deal
and man just take care of that skin dude
you really don't want to
look terrible in your later years so one
more time geology.com promo code stevo
and let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen kevin smith
yeah dude in the van in the creepy pedo
van i was uh walking back from runyon
canyon i try to exercise daily try but
um
as i was coming up the hill i saw this
monstrosity which
just sticks out like a sore thumb in the
neighborhood
and i was like oh my god they've come
for the children
somebody's out there offering lollipops
and [ __ ] like that and then it occurred
to me that uh they were like you're
gonna
to stevo's podcast and he comes to you
yeah and i was like that sounds hot and
they were like he don't come on you he
comes to you and i was like all right
i'll do that too um this is genius as a
guy who's been podcasting since
2007
never occurred to me
to take it mobile to like
soup up a [ __ ] vehicle this is
brilliant we were just talking about
before the show yeah this is the easiest
way to ask [ __ ] be on your
podcast yeah because you're if they're
like oh i got some [ __ ] like i'll show
up at your [ __ ] door you don't have
to you literally roll out in pajamas if
you like right brilliant man that's
smart well thank you man now um
you've uh been podcasting since 2007 for
how long have you been with our homeboy
dk uh deeker i mean i well deeker does
what deeker does
yeah and
to not alienate anybody dk is
our podcast guru we are not with the
podcast network we just have this guy dk
and he arranges the business of the the
advertising sponsors does a great job
and i love him because
i only uh promote
products that i'm down with yeah and and
so i think that with with podcast
networks you get
kind of told what you're going to
promote a lot of the time exactly i mean
i think so i've been around since before
podcast networks
well when we had two podcasts i i said
we have a podcast network
but now it's a legit business oh dude
it's insane what a business it is but
sorry i'm sorry
i've known for a while deker
i'm not taking credit for deker dieger
is a very smart guy and a hustler and
always has been however
he cut his teeth
on our podcast i was talking to dk on
the way up here and he said if it
weren't for kevin i would not have a
career in podcasting well yes like i was
very unemployable at the time and he
took a chance on me yes and no i would i
say deker smart enough to have always
wound up where he is
that being said yeah he was
the dude who you know was like
we were like see if you can get us some
advertising
and he started piecing it together and
kind of did that for years and then like
built a model
that he could then like take out into
the world and stuff they started working
with successful people
uh but he's absolutely wonderful one of
the smartest people i know probably not
supposed to tell us how to tell tales
out of school about him
but the one of the only sex addicts i've
ever known in my life wow like legit sex
addict where he had to put it aside
and not [ __ ] for a long time because he
was like
he he [ __ ] a lot it fascinated me when
he told me that what do you mean a sex
addict yeah and he was like i used to
[ __ ] nine ten times a day wow well now
now you've met two more sex addicts
because uh did you go in
like yeah to a program i i did an
intensive outpatient sex addict rehab
are you [ __ ] i swear to god what is
the difference between i like sex and i
need help i mean it's like a compulsive
compulsive sex that causes shame
is that right
see that i've never i've never
it's never been a shame when i've had
sex it's been a [ __ ] celebration so
i've never
felt that but my friend malcolm um is a
bear in toronto and he like just
he he was like at one point he was like
you got daddy told me he was gay he's
like you gotta [ __ ] go bear if you
want bear you get so [ __ ] man he's
like thank god no no hot directors
except peter jackson and he lost the
weight and [ __ ] so malcolm has always
been selling me on it and whatnot but
malcolm told me
like a [ __ ] bear bandit but he has
one of those apps growler grinder
i've got the grinder app
he's he
lived on that app and was like having
sex four or five times a day and he said
he felt that yeah that shame it was a
foreign notion of me where i'm like how
could you like you should feel fortunate
blessed but he was just like you just
get to a place where
it is absolutely
meaningless it's like
it's like drinking coors light all day
it doesn't do anything
who knew that that was [ __ ] possible
except you [ __ ] too right that's what
your podcast should be about that's
[ __ ] endlessly
revise scott's definition of of
addiction conviction in general as it
applies to any form of addiction is
continued behavior despite consequences
when something is [ __ ] up your life
but you keep doing it anyway and you
can't stop doing it because you have
this disease of addiction um so to where
i
met scott
his brother and i his brother's also a
double winner as we speak you just start
naming everybody
people listen and they're like boy i
wish i knew any of these people right a
double winner meaning um
someone who's made it into um two
different 12-step fellowships is that
right for addiction double black belt
right and um so that was i met scott
through his brother when i came out of
my
uh sex addict rehab i
had a bunch of tour dates on my schedule
and i was like i'm a dead duck you know
especially because after every show so
wait you're saying he was your sober
living companion what would you call it
[ __ ] blocker
that's how i met dieker okay dicker was
jay's slp oh there's a sober living pal
when he was in rehab and they let him
out for like you could go to comic-con
for two days but you got to take a sober
living companion with slc's i think
they're called we always call them sober
living pal so deeker was jay's
sober living pal forever and then that's
how we we met in the beginning so you
were that for sex yeah yeah
so when you're the sober living pal for
sex so you're like don't [ __ ] her i'll
jerk you off
i'll take the bullet
i'm a good friend
we would share like a hotel room so like
there's no going back to the you know
bringing chicks back or whatever and
what does one feel like
you know i'm i'm not a
i like food but not to the place where
well i guess i have like liked food to
the place where it was complicated
because i had a [ __ ] heart attack i
almost died so i guess i too am an
addict but um i i've
never
i the way i understand it because i've
known jason forever he's addict addict
takes one addiction away has to
substitute with another behavior so if
you take away sex what do you substitute
it with food
so you tend to gain weight when you go
to like sex rehab i just lost 30 pounds
after a sex week yeah
and you're like you know how i lost it
[ __ ]
a little yeah it it it can become a
little bit of a
whack-a-mole where you address one thing
and another issue pops up and um
you know i don't know that it's as
simple as saying uh you just replace a
behavior i mean like the whole concept
of 12-step is uh
you know sort of adopting a spiritual
approach to life and and service to
others and you know helping people and
now can i ask this question of course
when you were using or whatever you were
addicted to did you not feel those ways
in general like i think i know it means
you're selfish because you're like i
want to do things but even i know high
[ __ ] people they're always trying to
help others out and [ __ ] like that
they're always thinking of their fellow
man after they're fixed up i think i was
generally
a
pretty good guy you know i wasn't you
know i like towards the end of my run
with drugs and alcohol i developed
an ability to be quite mean-spirited um
you know i i became kind of a nasty
person
but
being addicted does not necessarily mean
you're a horrible person it's just that
the nature of addiction just makes you
you know like
when your only priority is to to keep
getting your fix
it's it's a selfish dynamic and and uh
it's a spiritual approach that let me
ask you this because we are uh cut from
a similar cloth
you are yourself for a living
yeah correct you wouldn't argue that
right i started as a filmmaker but i
slowly became myself
for a living
now i can't speak for you but i
my favorite thing in the world to do
possibly even more than [ __ ]
is be myself for a living because it's
just a mind [ __ ] where it's just like
i'm i'm i wake up and i'm on the job
like that that's [ __ ] fantastic
could that ever be an addiction
absolutely is that right yeah i mean uh
you're supposed to say no you mean you
mean fame or not so much fame but like
i like i
i use uh uh my professional life to
escape all manner of [ __ ] a lot of
people online oh you know over the
course of the
president's trump presidency were like
[ __ ] ah and [ __ ] like that i i'm not
that person if something pisses me off
i'm like i'm just gonna go right
rather because there's some [ __ ] you
cannot do anything about right and
in that way it's like well i can't shape
this world
i'm gonna go shape
my world i could definitely do that as
have you look at this we're in a [ __ ]
van recording podcast so you have shaped
your world is there a place
where
that's possibly too much could that ever
be an addiction i i think so
um
but
i think that like you got to eat right
you got to make a living right in in the
past like before uh i got clean and
sober with drugs and alcohol
i had no ability to to like turn it off
i was just ah crazy all the time i was
just a hundred percent you know this
wild guy and i really identified as the
persona of stevo and i was just crazy
all the time
and
i think that
what's dangerous whether it's an
addiction or not we can leave that aside
but what's dangerous is the idea of
being
identified with uh with this persona and
and having your self-worth
uh
derived from your value as a commodity
in the entertainment industry that would
be that would be mine right you might
have just nailed that on the head it's a
dangerous it's a dangerous dynamic
because you're commodifying yourself and
then you're right you're you are
only as good to yourself or as valuable
you feel as you are to the world so if
you're not a part of the conversation
right you're on a slippery slope yeah
when when you derive your self-esteem
from being in the spotlight
then uh
i think that one way or another the
spotlight will
you know it'll it'll shine elsewhere and
even if it's on you that's potentially
scarier because because what about you
know like our bodies deteriorate we
don't be you know that's the scariest
thing for me because i'm at my core just
an attention [ __ ]
look at me look at me were you a class
clown
sure big time right and not even good at
it you know i think all of my behavior
just alienated my peers but
but i noticed
and
it occurs to me that that in our society
like i would bet that if you surveyed
100 people that was that that
there are a lot of people would not know
what the definition of the word hospice
is
i say that i think that's important
because
everybody knows what a hospital is
because you go to the hospital to get
better but the idea of a hospice being
somewhere where you go and you don't get
better you go and die people don't want
to think about that you know and people
don't even want to deal with elderly
people it's like being old in itself is
a party foul yeah
you want they just want to stuff you
away in a nursing home they don't even
want to look at you because you serve as
a reminder of
everyone that's more than happy
yeah and so but yet our job is to
distract from that of course that's like
our main function in life is be like
and for a few seconds [ __ ] for a
few seconds [ __ ] looking at us
has forgotten right the ultimate truth
which is like i'm bound for a hospice
one dude 100 this is shaping up to be a
fascinating conversation because i
couldn't agree with you more i re i
really couldn't now being an attention
[ __ ] and recognizing that that
elderly
people are walking party valves that
nobody wants to pay attention to it's
like
now oh wait a second yeah there's an
expiration date on this [ __ ] right
that's so that's so scary walking party
foul well that's what what people are
isn't it
isn't it evolution though you know you
began life as um
an attention [ __ ] yep and
undoubtedly
got a lot of attention yep so when one
seeks and one finds and gets that
ameliorates what drove one in the first
place you gotta grow so
i don't i i think you could be
older i don't think you'll ever be old
like what the traditional but i think
you'd be older and still hold a cool
edge i submit to you george carlin man
was [ __ ] cool until the moment he was
guys still cool now he's been dead like
[ __ ] 10 years
and he was old yeah i submit another one
stan lee old as [ __ ] he was old from the
moment i knew him when they brought him
to mall rats they told us be careful
this man's 76 he could go at any minute
he lived another 20 years and the man
who said that to me that he could go at
any minute died way before stanley
well i i i think you'll maintain
i think you'll be live the you will
redefine the silver fox well thank you i
appreciate the kind words greatly i i do
believe that uh as i've already
uh kind of proven that i'm able to
evolve absolutely you know and and i
think that i will have my own approach
when i get bummed out about the idea of
being middle-aged elderly i think man
you know like i'm gonna be
these ages
like in a fashion that nobody's ever
done before yeah man you get to recreate
it right if you look at a thing and
you're like i don't like how that thing
is you've spent your whole life changing
that right so why would this be any
[ __ ] different you'll get to redefine
age and people will be like well that's
a way to do it right and then they'll
invite the old man to the party he won't
be a party foul right it'll be a party
plus yeah i love that and and going back
to
what i was saying about how i couldn't
turn it off yeah when when i didn't
because dude i was a [ __ ] disaster it
was it was it was gnarly
you're very jason museum yeah yes very
good you guys are very much of the same
cloth it got it got ugly especially
because i think jason muse was a little
bit more like isolating isolated he was
more behind closed doors and you would
have to eventually he got to that point
because once he got to like the
harder stuff once he was to heroin
that's not like hey who wants to hang
out and do heroin like you want to talk
about depressing people yeah really
on the podcast that like
you took him to the mall and he had to
stay with you you guys were walking
around that was literally
sit i i was a sober living companion
before i knew that you can get paid for
that sort of thing
[ __ ] oh yeah absolutely but yeah it's
he
he was a guy who would eventually be by
himself you seem like a party guy that
was like
in the midst of it all i put together a
mailing list of uh 200 of the most
influential people who
whose contact info i had and barraged
them around the clock 24 hours a day
with my downward spiral
sharing it that's very kind of you know
most people don't get to experience that
i was an attention [ __ ] at my worst but
and a cautionary tale for sure
for sure
and then getting sober i kind of
identified like oh wow you know there's
this like
you know like the path that i was on
wasn't
headed anywhere good so i really need to
find some separation between the persona
of stevo and then like whoever i am as a
person you know who now
when you think
you know like uh there's a
episode of
batman the animated series
when um he met uh the mad hatter and the
mad hatter like you know he didn't know
most of the episode he was in a dream
and at the end he [ __ ] figures it out
that he's in a dream and [ __ ]
and so like alfred i think it is you
know the coda of the episode is just
like how did you
figure it out and he goes because in the
dream that
that hatter was creating for me
i was bruce wayne
and he was like but when i really dream
i'd dream as batman so he knew he's like
this is fake this is unreal who do you
dream as do you dream as the persona or
do you dream as the kid yeah what a
great question
and is there a difference between the
two
there's a lot there it blends a lot i
would say a dream not as the persona i
believe but what what's interesting is
this sort of lived the dream [ __ ]
yeah i think what's interesting is that
um you know as the more
like mindful i was to sort of establish
an identity separate from the persona
um
and and to really like pay attention to
uh to all of this like spiritual
practice
the better i got at managing the persona
you know like the reality was when i
couldn't turn it off when i was just
[ __ ] nuts all day long
i was not [ __ ] good at being stevo i
was not good at managing the business of
stephen i was not good at uh cleverly
strategically mapping out a game plan
and and in sobriety
uh i i've taken away a lot of
distractions i've taken away a lot of
handicaps and i've i've become
more and more
just laser focused on what i want to
accomplish and i've been really [ __ ]
productive and and god is kind of good
at it how long you got now 14 years of
chemical sobriety five years of sexual
sobriety and now i'm uh
like in in the food deal my latest run
with uh
food is i'm
about 70 days of taking a photo of every
single meal before i eat it and sending
it to my mentor in the food program what
is that about what do you mean i just
got so gnarly out of control with sugar
i don't even look as much like a guy
i've lost a lot of weight over the last
70 days you have never occurred to me
right as
anything but a thin person wow but dude
like we'll leave a comedy club that
night and he'll get like you know two
brownies with ice cream on it and like
why why would you do that
it's just compulsive behavior
is it to compound the joy like you're
coming off the stage and you're like
holy [ __ ] i rocked it
the adrenaline high everyone in this
room [ __ ] loves me what would make
this better
sex booze drugs food for me it's food
it's just like i
like i do hollywood babylon with ralph
and we have for like
12 years we used to do it at uh
the improv all the time now we're at
flappers and burbank with ralph ralph
garmin is a friend of mine he used to be
on k rock okay yeah yeah yeah and the
morning show
the the kevin and bean show so him and
i've been doing this podcast called
hollywood babylon for like 12 years it's
a total like nightclub show it's real
fun and [ __ ] but
when the show is done
like ralph hangs out at the bar and
drinks and
not like problematically just he enjoys
that and hangs out with people and [ __ ]
like that i get in the car and i
come home
and traditionally it was always like now
i'm gonna go to my office
and like eat
because
i did good i deserve this i was very
much and still am and we'll fight for
ever being a rewards eater
okay and it feels like your rewards
everything i mean i think yeah like i
did it i'm gonna throw this on top but i
think uh in addiction it's like if
you're if you're bummed out you know
like you you soothe yourself with with
your reward you know whatever the the
comfort seeking behavior is when is it
okay though when is it just allowed to
be a good thing and not i think
i think
what addiction does come down to is like
you know being addicted to shame
there is no question that sex addiction
brings about shame and that's why a
healthier approach to sexuality is so
important and
thank god for blue chew because not only
is blue chew helping my approach to
sexuality be healthier it's helping me
approach sexuality with a massive boner
and that's right you heard me say it i
take my blue chew tablets and that is a
declaration of war on lux's vagina yeah
i said it we have sex after i take my
bluetooth tablets now if you're in the
dark here what's a bluetooth tablet it's
a delicious chewable tablet with the
same active ingredients as both viagra
and cialis except it costs only a
fraction of the price
and for you the loyal wild ride listener
you can get an entire month's supply of
bluetooth tablets absolutely for free
you just gotta pay five bucks for
shipping and
very quickly and conveniently consult
with the medical provider at
bluetooth.com
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
stevo now if you're on the fence about
this wondering but our bluetooth tablets
like fun am i gonna like have a lot of
fun with a raging boner having awesome
sex the answer is yes so jump on this
deal man go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code stevo get an entire month's
supply of bluetooth tablets absolutely
for free all you gotta pay is five bucks
for shipping and scott's talking about
shame i am not ashamed of my bluetooth
tablets i love them and so will you so
one more time bluechew.com promo code
stevo have a great time and let's get
back to this
and i think like that's the kind of
bottom
line is like
that would you
core belief about yourself and like
feeling shitty and so you're doing
things that make you feel shitty and
then like you know it's self-fulfilling
there's a lot of that is that based on
brene brown someone telling you like hey
you're bad or do you just feel bad i
think like growing up like thinking
you're bad or doing whatever you kind of
like were told as a kid and then in your
subconscious it kind of sticks around so
you seek out those behaviors that like
for example this is an extreme version
of it but some kid
um i knew was born in a dumpster
so he thought he was a piece of [ __ ] the
[ __ ] so he would do he would like
sexually do things that like would make
him feel like a piece of [ __ ] how do you
get born in a dumpster homeless have fun
it's like a homeless lady wow his mom
was homeless and she
i mean look
that's close to the jesus story right
born in a manger you know that's not a
cool place to be born but the sad thing
is the
that it haunted him for the rest of his
life something he had no control over
right yeah but he was like well you know
he was pissed off at god and he's like
you know maybe i am a piece of [ __ ] i
was born in a trash can and then like so
you know
that evolved into like just toxic
behaviors that you carry out later
because it kind of matches up with your
core belief what you think about
yourself right i think it's also
a little bit um
erroneous to try to make logic of
addiction too you know like you you
can't like always it's true you can't
always figure out the origin of it it's
not like a direct abc correlation yeah
my my my sponsor always says it doesn't
matter how the jackass got into the
ditch just get it out yeah right for
sure it doesn't matter what started the
fire put the [ __ ] fire out right like
you all have traveled
internationally and been around the
world
i'm an international star scott randolph
there you go you're all continental he
and i have traveled the world [ __ ]
extensively so here's my question as
somebody who knows what addiction looks
like is familiar with it
do you feel
this country
is more addictive
than other countries i i my feeling is
america the american
sensibility like you know [ __ ]
the pursuit of happiness which is
[ __ ] right there um in in the
founding one of the founding documents
of this country
i think
it's a very
uniquely american ideal
to have something that's good and then
want to make it better and make it last
all the time right like that there was a
phenomenon of craving that buddhism
talks about what is it explain whatever
your situation is you you want to
improve it if you're in pain you want
the pain to end if you feel good you
want the the good feeling to be
intensified and to last longer yes so
wait is that so so that's what it would
have to say about to say that they're
like don't do that
you just have to to not let your craving
uh you know
dictate your life that that really that
happiness is going to come
not from uh improving your your
situation but rather accepting what is
you know sort of uh being in the present
and and accepting the moment of as it is
and not getting too caught up in
improving the the moment is it wrong to
want
something good
to happen
as frequently as possible
i don't think i don't think so but
what where the the line
i think lives and i think you're really
really uh onto something by pointing to
america as being problematic is that and
i love the country don't get me wrong
but it's of course we are winning but
america is not better all the time and
it's like right there's always something
better than this like you don't think
about it we're marketed to on a regular
basis the whole world is but america is
[ __ ] exceptional it's making you
believe that like
a [ __ ] iphone's not good enough you
got to get a new one right so like seems
to be more addiction in america versus
like elsewhere
yeah i think so and i think that america
is more caught up in the pursuit of
pleasure yes than the pursuit of
happiness you're absolutely right i
think you nailed it right there mine is
between pleasure and happiness and now
dude i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you this
crazy thing
um i don't think i've ever said it on
this podcast but i i didn't want to kids
i didn't want to have kids for for a
whole bunch of reasons right um
genetically like every leaf on my family
tree
is like suffers from
alcoholism
addiction gambling suicide you know my
mom's side of the family literally every
[ __ ] person that we can identify
through the family tree is all dead from
that [ __ ] you know like i'm the first
one to to break the curse right so
passing on the genetics is is
problematic and then there's
the
the this whole dynamic of the rich
getting richer and the poor getting
poorer which just stopped being [ __ ]
funny you know like
it's
we're really at a point where it's
[ __ ] up i mean
and i said this to my buddy i've one
friend i've known since we were both
nine years old in fourth grade
his name's abdullah and um
his family's from sudan he's devout
muslim i used to
spend so much time at his house and i
would pray to mecca with abdullah when
we were just kids
and
we graduated high school together he
went on to brown university got a 4.0
then he went to cornell medical school
then he became a pediatric surgeon at
the mayo clinic has since invented ways
of operating on
babies that are still in the womb and
have not yet been born
and he's the most like just unbelievably
like
wonderful person he's such a gift to the
world and our paths are very different
but we've kept in touch forever now i
was talking to abdullah
probably 10 years ago now and i'm saying
i don't want to have kids
he's shocked
and i said dude abdullah for our parents
um
uh
university diploma meant placement in a
career of your choosing for us not so
much for our kids it means student debt
it's a nightmare like the the the
dwindling opportunity in the world is
really uh upsetting to me and i don't
want it on my conscience that i created
a human being to to struggle and suffer
right abdullah looks at me like i'm
[ __ ]
out of my mind and he says
in africa
where with all of the
the
famine the poverty the disease
do you think
people are less happy
now my god
response my initial reaction is well
[ __ ] yeah they're less happy
but
he he tells me they're not and and and i
understand intellectually what
abdullah's point is which is that you
can
strip
people of of their health of their their
their ability to eat of their you know
their shelter everything but you cannot
strip a human being of their capacity to
love another and that is what true
happiness is derived from is
loving another and so
it's pretty heavy
i went ahead and got the vasectomy
you're like all right abdullah i hear
you
but to a point
i'm just gonna hedge my bets
yeah
he saved his sperm just in case right
you did you save a violence
i i think i would be a reasonably good
father but i just like uh
there's the genetics there's the
societal concerns and then there's just
the fact that i'm a kid and i'm always
going to be a kid the best dad in the
world jason muse hands down best father
i've ever seen jason muse was a better
father than i was
and i wish he had had a kid before i'd
had a kid because i would have seen how
you should do it
um you know there was a guy who a lot of
people wrote off as a [ __ ] mess and
an addict and [ __ ] like that he's been
clean and sober now for over 10 years 12
years and hands down the best father
i've ever seen that kid
like
is entertained
by a one-man show
throughout her whole [ __ ] life a show
that most people like here's some money
do some funny [ __ ] and whatnot and she
gets it for free all the time you'd be
the same kind of [ __ ] father i i
don't doubt it uh and i appreciate that
i think that like
i i have uh a profound
respect for the idea of parenthood and
um
i think a lot of people don't
but
and as fascinating as this conversation
is i feel like it is turning into one
where it's just me talking about me a
lot and i wanted to know
i wanted to ask you am i correct that
you wrote this song too fat to fly
the song yeah was it did you write a
song called no i was involved in an
incident
that i called and then others adopted as
too fat to fly when i got thrown off of
a southwest
air airplane and i was tweeting about it
and it [ __ ] went viral i think it was
johnny knoxville's cousin roger allen
wade the country singer who wrote a song
too fat to fly it might have been after
i'm not certainly not taking credit but
it could have been inspired by that it's
so so wow that was now
getting kicked off an airplane for being
too fat
it was
they were never like they never gave me
a clear thing there's somebody who
wasn't from southwest who was like look
i know a little bit about airlines
and when an airplane is fully loaded and
that plane was like fully loaded and i
was absolutely the last one on i was
supposed to be on the next flight but i
was like oh [ __ ] there's a
seat on this plane [ __ ] i'll get on it
so this person who's involved with
airlines is just like they have weights
on planes and like
you were just the last person on it
wasn't like you're too [ __ ] fat for
this plane they were like we're over the
weight limit somebody's got to go who's
the last person that came on they're
like that guy howdy guys how much did
you weigh at that time um over three
bills i think i weighed my my like uh
area code at that point three two three
wow yeah yeah but still i wore it fairly
well i'm not gonna say like i you know i
could [ __ ] fool you and [ __ ] but
i i did it was always spread out fairly
well so much so that people were like
really you were that [ __ ] heavy um
but yeah that was
the center after the heart attack that
was way before maybe way before when was
the heart attack heart attack was four
and a half years ago and well four years
ago in february that just passed what
does that feel like
it was
didn't feel like a heart attack you know
i was raised on [ __ ] 70s television
so i was waiting to fred sanford that
[ __ ] like
you know you're supposed to be big [ __ ]
your chest
[ __ ] yell somebody's name
and really i just couldn't quite catch
my breath and i was between performances
i was doing a show at uh the alex
theater in uh
pasadena i think or glendale glendale
and um
we were shooting them for a showtime
special you know when you do a show that
you shoot two shows and then they
combine it into sure into one so we shot
the first show
and i got backstage and also and i just
couldn't quite like catch my breath
and i was like um can everyone get out
of here i just want to like lay down for
a second and [ __ ] because we had another
show in like 45 minutes
and then i was like sweating profusely
and couldn't quite like catch my breath
that was it didn't feel
anything didn't feel chest pain or
anything
and so jason's wife jordan she runs our
company
she was like concerned she's like i
never see you like this so
she called an ambulance and at one point
she hadn't told me
at one point i finally broke down i was
like you know what i feel very [ __ ] up
like maybe we should call a doctor she's
like it's sunday night all the doctors
are close so i called in the ambulance
and i was like why the [ __ ] would you do
that this is embarrassing i just smoked
too much weed that's all the problem is
and the first responders came and they
these two kids this guy and this girl
you know like in production as you're
well aware they put together a call
sheet for those that don't know that is
all the information you need for the
shoot that day who's on it who does what
where [ __ ] what time you're starting so
forth there's also information like in
case of an emergency this is the
hospital that we go to
so there was a hospital on the call
sheet that was way close to the theater
the kids the first responders decided to
take me to a further hospital because
they were
heart specialists
so they made the call they didn't even
tell me i was having a heart attack they
put these [ __ ] leads on me i was more
concerned
with how they wanted to like uh take my
shirt off because they're like we gotta
attach the leads to you at one point the
guy went to just hike my hockey jersey
up i was like whoa yanked it down
every [ __ ] tit i got is gonna fall
out
he was like well we gotta get these
leads on you i was like well you [ __ ]
reach under i'll hold out the hockey
dude you reach under use my tits too
that's a godpost and go ahead so i was
giving them a problem because i was like
embarrassed and stuff about my body all
my body shame issues when i
and they in the midst of all that they
were like had presence of mind to be
like this motherfucker's having a heart
attack
we should bring them to the heart attack
hospitals they brought me to adventist
and uh
that made the difference there was this
guy mark ladenheim dr leidenheim who i
get into the
to the emergency room
and he's like uh hi
how you feeling and i was like i feel
like
fine i just can't catch my breath i
can't like i can breathe but i can't
reach the top and come back down and he
was just like uh well you know what's
your pain level on a scale of zero to
ten
and i was like pain like negative three
and he's like oh that's [ __ ] up he's
like you're doing it all wrong i was
like doing it wrong he's like yeah
you're supposed to be in a lot of pain
when you have a heart attack
and i was like am i you're saying i'm
having a heart attack usually you're
having a massive heart attack right now
now i'm not one to point fingers but i
think what kevin is describing is that
he wasn't taking very good care of
himself and maybe that's why he had a
heart attack now i respectfully submit
that if kevin had been
using athletic greens
that maybe
that wouldn't happen i don't know but i
do know that athletic greens ag-1 is
absolutely the most convenient
comprehensive
like just healthy supplement that you
can have plus it's totally delicious
it's like this green powder that you put
in a pine of water first thing in the
morning so you get hydrated and what's
in it well 75 different vitamins
minerals whole foods source
superfoods
probiotics adaptogens i mean this stuff
is magic man it fills in all of the gaps
in your diet if you think man maybe i'm
not eating that healthy then boom this
is going to solve that problem fills the
gaps in your diet it helps with your gut
health it helps your cognitive abilities
because it's just plain good for your
brain i'm telling you and it's delicious
i use it all the time and you'd be crazy
if you didn't so let's start taking care
of ourselves go to athleticgreens.com
stevo and what are you going to get well
with your first order you're going to
get five convenient comprehensive travel
packs of athletic greens ag-1 plus an
entire year's supply of vitamin d which
boosts the immune system and man it's
all good stuff this just makes you
healthy so start taking care of yourself
one more time you're going to
athleticgreens.com
stevo
and that's all there is to it your first
order they're going to load you up with
good healthy stuff and you're going to
be on that train like me and kevin smith
now taking care of ourselves no more
heart attacks people get on it
athleticgreens.com
stevo now let's talk about that heart
attack
he's like we gotta go very very fast so
i'm gonna meet you upstairs in the or
and then they turned me over to a guy
who was just like um
i gotta shave your groin because that's
how the doctor's gonna get into your
heart so can you take your jorts off or
whatever
and so uh i was like um
well i don't wanna do that in front of
these people you know [ __ ] er
everybody there i don't give a [ __ ] like
everybody got their own emergency going
on but like we've all been in an er i
don't care if your mom's dying sooner or
later you look around and be like what
the [ __ ] you know so sooner or later
somebody's going to look around and be
like is that silent bob and his dick out
so i was like i'm not i'm not taking off
my
my uh jewelry
death before dishonor it truly was
surely it wasn't just like are you
kidding we gotta go and i was like well
what if i just like pull my [ __ ]
jorts over to the side and you could
just give me a virgin smoothie or
whatever
and he's like uh do you realize we're
wasting time i was like look man that
dude that dude was just here he told me
i had a heart attack if you make me take
my pants off and go dick out in this
room i'm of a second heart attack that's
gonna be on you so they got me up to the
o.r and the doctor's like why is his
pants still on and the guy was like he's
got body shame issues i was like doc i
got a really small dick he goes we don't
have time for this he yanked my [ __ ] off
like i was in the 70s porn man
and [ __ ] went it works so they in
order to uh
you know there's many different ways to
figure out what's going on in the heart
the doctor suspected it was some sort of
blockage or what the medical people call
an occlusion
so he uh
threaded a camera up my femoral artery
how to get to it is two ways they could
go in through your wrist or then going
through your femoral which is like in
your crotch in your groin area so they
puncture a hole and [ __ ] go up they
stick a camera up the femoral and he's
like oh that's exactly what i thought it
was and i was like what's that he's gone
uh you got 100 blockage um and in your
uh lad that's the name of the artery
that comes down
um so we gotta
we gotta break it up and and get a stent
in there as soon as possible then he
goes but he's going you're a comic book
guy you like comic books right and i was
like very much then he's like they got a
name for this heart attack it's called
the widow maker he goes doesn't that
sound like a bad guy in a comic book i
was like it does what's it mean as if
you had to ask and he's just like well
in the particular heart attack you're
having with the 100 blockage
80 percent of the cases the patient
always dies he's going to be in the 20
because i'm good at my job and he
disappeared into my crotch and made
magic and [ __ ] so
dude saved my [ __ ] life but while i
was on the table
80 20 you know i'm no math genius but i
know that those are terrible [ __ ]
odds you know i figure every time you
leave the house it's 50 50 but 80 20.
yes
man that's terrible so i started going
through the whole like you know well if
my life's going to flash proof of my
eyes i'm going to start this [ __ ]
movie and just tracked my existence up
until that point and thought about like
everything that worked out and
very
very little didn't work out in life and
like you know i was like well
if this is it like you you got a good
[ __ ] run like yeah you're only
[ __ ] 47 but like
packs a lot of [ __ ] crazy living in
47 [ __ ] years so
if this is the end like don't be a [ __ ]
about it just push back from the table
say thank you and [ __ ] go don't be
the last dude struggling to stay at the
party where you got any more [ __ ]
beer like just go leave the [ __ ]
party yeah i love that i reached the
place i reached a place of like
total zen where i was like i'm ready and
then [ __ ] saved my life so i had
to come back to the land of the living
and that's [ __ ] up when you're like
all right i'm ready to die and they're
like well you're not gonna you're like
oh [ __ ] it's not like i was suicidal and
i wasn't emo and i wasn't like [ __ ]
goth like i just want to diamond but i
was like i get it like my whole life
i've been scared to death and then on
that table maybe it was because he gave
me the odds maybe it's because i was
hopped up on fentanyl who [ __ ] knows
but yeah i sat there going like
you know
this is i remember you know as a big big
fan of neil gaiman's sandman book which
is now on netflix as a show but back in
the day it was just comic book and in
the issue about death his sister death
was personified by this like goth girl
and [ __ ] she's going around collecting
souls all day you know people that are
dying they're like oh my god i know who
you are and [ __ ] and she takes them
wherever they're gonna go she comes this
one guy
an older dude and he's just like no
no it's too soon she's going yeah and
he's like well
my whole life i had this and he listed
all this [ __ ] like you know all the
[ __ ] he'd been through he's like all
that happened to me and what what did i
get
and the death character says to him you
got what everybody gets you got a life
so i'm sitting there going i got a life
and [ __ ] that life was great and
it ends like it felt it occurred to me
as graduation the first time in my life
i wasn't afraid of death because i was
like oh
you can't stay in high school forever
sooner or later
and
i felt like
i was like yeah truly
i get older they say the same age but
but it was like a moment of like oh it's
it's natural it's right like it was
always you know
the enemy to me you know when you're a
creative person or you fancy yourself a
creative person or you get paid to do
creative things for a living
death is just
[ __ ] a slap in the face it's so
insulting it's like what i can't end i
have important [ __ ] to do there's so
much here and i just want to thank you
for how [ __ ] fascinating all of that
was well it's the van that brings it up
and uh scott randolph here
had like has watched and continues to
watch every night
hundreds thousands of video testimonies
about nde near-death experiences yeah
right is that your thing every night
before i go to bed i watch this this guy
on youtube called lee whitting
and he's in bangor maine i'm trying to
like reach out to him because i want to
meet up with him but he's like a
hospital chaplain that has a podcast and
he interviews people that have died and
come back and you know they're hard to
stop for four minutes nine minutes
sometimes like i think the record's like
30 minutes
mom what happened to my mom long before
i had a heart attack my mom has always
had like heart problems and [ __ ]
and uh
she died on the table and so she you
know [ __ ] had a very familiar story
about like there was a light and did she
go to the light
she
she described it well let's all agree
that the light is probably the hospital
light you know
no because sometimes people are saying
like you know they're floating above
their body true and then all of a sudden
there's a light in the corner true and
then they go to it and then they go do a
live review which i'm fascinated by the
life reviews oh yeah she said she saw
like dad because my dad died years ago
she saw my grandma she saw familiar
people
and she was like
she and then she got yanked back and so
i was like all right ma
you've been here in this best of all
possible worlds for many years and you
were there
for almost a minute
which did you like better
and [ __ ] she [ __ ] me up by going
like there there and i said why
and she goes
i felt so light she's gone every [ __ ]
pressure and every every
hook in me that i felt in life all the
[ __ ] that i'm responsible for
i was i was done like suddenly i was
like oh my god and she was all that
responsibility
was was offered i thought that was
really beautiful and when
i was going through my thing so i don't
know if her
thing informed my thing
but like i too once i was just like oh
[ __ ] i'm probably gonna [ __ ] this is
the last ceiling i'm gonna see
in is in this room and
you know i was that should have [ __ ]
like terrified me and [ __ ] like that but
the
the
the hook of it
was that like oh
this is
th this is
like
i you know i was raised catholic so
there's supposed to be something after
this
and over the years of course i've let go
of that
and i've you know i think scott moser we
do podcasts where we did a podcast for
years called spodcast
he had said at one point he's you know
he was not raised religious or anything
and moser was like um you know i was
talking about
dying
long before i ever almost died and i was
like what do you [ __ ] think happens
after this like you don't believe in
heaven come on dude like there's got to
be something after this
and he's like well you believe in heaven
because you were fed that when you were
a kid
he's going but you're way too logical to
really believe in that if you step aside
and think about it who's going to
understand that you were raised with it
and whatnot but like
i don't think it's that and he's going
you believe there's a heaven because
you know you just cannot [ __ ]
stand the notion
that one day you ain't gonna think these
thoughts that the world's not gonna
share in the glory of [ __ ] you and
whatnot and he's like but
i think i was like what do you think it
is he's gone i think we're computers
he's gone the computer has a massive
amount of information on it because
that's what i was saying i was like how
could i just [ __ ] stop and die like i
have all this information and he was
just like a computer is packed with
information he could do amazing [ __ ]
things he's gone and then one day just
hard drive spins down and that's it
and i was like [ __ ] that that was the
first time it
it really impacted with me where i was
like
oh you're right there is no heaven and
i'm not special none of us are and what
we have in this life
is what we have and what we build and
that's the [ __ ] adventure and all
these [ __ ] people that are fed a line
of [ __ ] about suffering in this
world and [ __ ]
you know rewarding the next is like what
a what a [ __ ]
what a bunch of hokum that is it's like
you got no nobody [ __ ] knows what's
on the other side and if you really
think about it it's probably nothing so
this is it
well joy is here man there ain't no joy
after this it's just you just wind down
like a computer i i'm with your mom you
believe in the i yeah and and um
i i believe that all religions
effectively
uh point to the same
like universal truth which is
distilled down to the words we are one
sure
we are one and what we are one means
as i understand it and i think that this
is across all
scriptures and and stuff i mean
is that
uh
creation
um
everything that exists in the universe
is an exercise in god
experiencing itself because god being
one thing
cannot
uh have experience because experience is
based on relativity one thing relating
to another and one thing cannot relate
to itself
so
big bang whatever creation you want to
call it is this one thing
dividing itself into separate particles
which
now
can relate to one another because
there's that that separation but the
separation is an illusion it's it's it's
an illusion which allows for
you know uh
up
there's no up if there's no down there's
no hot if there's no cold these are all
relative terms
and so
i another fun way to distill it down
somebody said this to me and it really
stuck we are all eyes in the same head
so to go to [ __ ] good it's a really
good one that was really good to go to
to scott would scott bring up with the
the life review
life review is just beyond uh
indisputable there's just so much
evidence there's so much life review is
like the life lifestyle
now i've read an article um that's the
scientific piece that was like this is
absolutely true yeah you do experience
your life before you die and
i don't know if it's theoretical or if
it's uh
medical but what they came up with was
when the body is going through the
trauma
of shutting down which is something
we're not familiar with because most of
our lives the body is vital and [ __ ]
doing the things that we want it to do
when the body shuts down it is traumatic
like because the body's not used to like
oh this ain't going to be used no more
we're dying and it shuts down
the brain releases a chemical
the dmt keeps you calm
my my question with that is
the the near-death experiences all seem
to be the same
maybe it's dmt releasing from your brain
however the people that do ayahuasca or
that do dmt don't have the same
experiences as
that and so i'm always wondering like if
it is the dmt
you'd never hear somebody come back from
an ayahuasca trip saying i went to the
light i met my spirit guides right it's
always another dimension
that's what i've been trying to think
about is predisposition like uh you know
uh everyone sees the same little green
men like the mechanical elves yeah is it
says something like somebody they've
been telling this [ __ ] go to the
light and hey you see everybody and your
old pets and [ __ ] like that that's
interesting for years is it just part of
us now that like even if you're not a
faithful person or a religious person
that is something to cling to in the
darkness
like in a world where nobody [ __ ]
knows at least when you've got a faith
you're like well i put my faith in jesus
and jesus says it's going to be this but
let's say you don't have a jesus
and all you got is [ __ ] like oh that
i'll take that like maybe that's enough
but how do you explain like um
one of the girls that died she said um
you know i left my body i went into the
other hallways
and i saw she's like i saw my stepdad
getting a coca-cola from the vending
machine and he came an hour later
and she's like but i thought it was
interesting because he's always like
older than thou exercise guy and she's
like i made a mental note like that's
weird he's getting a diet coke and then
she kept going and then when she came
back she said maybe like you know a
couple days later she's like
did you get a diet coke out of the
vending machine and he was like how did
you know that and it was like a little
secret that he had or he was eating a
snickers bar
i mean there's like interesting outer
body experiences yeah there's definitely
proof in that regard but i think it's
more simple than whether there's dmt or
some kind of uh
a physiological thing because all of
these accounts of life review and again
life review is your life passing before
your eyes
is
they all
uh take time out of the equation right
like it's it's it's a flash but it's
like that you can see the whole story
the detail is time doesn't exist and
then they say they feel everybody's pain
that they put exactly that's that's one
thing that that that's the thing is that
that's common yeah yeah
all of them that do have life reviews
say they go through and experience
everybody's pain that i put them through
i enjoy i've got the gnarliest that
means it's true the gnarliest goosebumps
okay like what what the concept of we
are all one we're all eyes in the same
head
like this this uh illusion of separation
the life review is an is an experience
that that does not um
involve time the detail is is insane you
actually go through
your
your whole life it and at the
detail that you can't even like describe
as a human being but you go through your
whole life and you experience
your
impact on
everything else so every time you made
every time you made someone happy you're
gonna feel that joy every time you made
someone
uh
more obsessed i did more pro than than
so i'm looking forward to that but wait
the do you get life review if you live
everybody but like if you're yeah the
near-death experience they they've had
them um it's like they'll come back and
ask if they had a life review and maybe
20 will say no i didn't but like the
majority are like yeah i one guy went
and he said he
his guy took him around and then he sat
him down in a movie theater and a thing
came on and you watched his movie like
there's different ways to do it yeah and
you can experience
how like you can experience it like
as a mosquito that's off in the distance
like so far away from when you did the
most minor thing and like and so
it's just uh i'm in
can you induce this huh can you reduce
it
yeah they i guess in the east coast they
have um they shut off your senses and
they're trying to recreate so when they
put you in like an outer box
something there's a i've been trying to
look into it and i want to pay for it to
do it you're a [ __ ] searcher man look
at you you're a seeker good for you have
you ever have you ever been to a place
that you thought was familiar like i
like
what i mean by that is like i think in
the past life i was vietnamese is that
right i think and that was also
brazilian because i have like a weird
kinship with vietnamese people and when
i went to vietnam i was like oh this is
familiar do you have anything like that
i've always loved canada for no
explicable reason
so i must have been canadian and that
makes a lot of [ __ ] sense you know
because canadians are good people
in general so they of course they'd be
reincarnated you know you're coming back
you did it right you get to do it again
maybe in a past life you're a canadian i
think so it's got to be there's no good
reason to explain why i like canada as
much as i do
and it's interesting because both of you
guys i mean me too and everybody like
i feel so blessed in this life me too
and i and i and i was asking about that
and they said because you were probably
un evolved in a previous life and like
you
it's like kind of like a karmic you know
i'm really enjoying this life and the
only way i can explain it is that like i
must have been a really good person in a
previous life
is that
i don't know what i mean look i'll take
that because i like that but
so do [ __ ] heels get a better life next
time around or does their life get worse
i think like maybe murderers get
reincarnated a little bit lower on the
life
i think you're looking at it like far
too simplistically
and um
and i think that when conversations with
god he asked him how many lives he's had
he's like seven hundred or whatever he
said right right right right right right
i mean
but you could choose to come back to
this world if you want when you go to
the other side or you can go
what's the soul contract i mean do you
want to explain that
there's there's there's a soul contract
where like you uh you have like a
blueprint for what you want to uh to
experience what you want to uh remember
what you when you know you choose your
parents you
you you go into this and and the
contract that which we uh
enter into you know as we before we
incarnate as a body
like the deal is once you incarnate as a
body like you forget that the whole deal
that's like uh
there was a movie years or years and
years ago in the late 80s maybe early
90s called angel heart with mickey
rourke
and he was uh it was a detective gumshoe
economy
where they the side story to that
allegedly i wasn't there i wasn't even
in the movie business but allegedly they
actually
had sex while they were shooting their
sex scene wow that's like if you go on
the internet there's lots of stories
about that in any event it's a story
about a guy
mickey rourke's a detective who's hired
by
robert de niro plays a character named
louis cipher
figure that out um he wants him to track
down
this guy johnny angel who owes him
something and so mickey rourke's looking
for this [ __ ] guy the whole movie and
spoilers in the third act
you find out that he was johnny angel
and he made a deal with the devil
to like become [ __ ] famous and [ __ ]
like that and they tried to renege on
the deal with the devil
and forgot who he was and so the devil
had come to claim his [ __ ] soul and
sent him to look for it and [ __ ] like
that now when clerks happened to me in
1994
i you know i was now i'm like you i'm an
outsider artist like there was no
manifest that that was going to happen i
lived in new jersey the [ __ ] is not
like i lived in college it wasn't
manifest that you could make a hit movie
with twenty seven thousand dollars go
figure it out go figure it
really i was looking for the manifest
and there wasn't so when we clerks like
not when i made it but when it got
bought and when it was clear that like
oh my god like my dream is actually
going to come true
i was convinced that i had angel hearted
myself that i had made some deal with
the devil and part of the deal was that
i would not remember until it was too
[ __ ] late and [ __ ] now i still got
time in this life i hope i don't find
out that's the [ __ ] case but i like
the notion of the soul contract where
it's just like
you're gonna you get to pick and choose
the menu but you ain't gonna remember
any of this [ __ ] right i'm like like
also
a big researcher a big thing and
this
one hang up that i have with the the
because in the soul contract in the
blueprint for life which we agreed to
um
there are pre-determined
events which are just going to happen
and i can't pre-existing conditions yes
even after life there's pre-existing
conditions there's a well not
pre-existing but predetermined
like things that are gonna happen and i
just cannot reconcile
uh
free will
with pre-determination yeah that's an
interesting conversation
that's what i want to ask a big thing
for lifelong catholics man it's just
like well
i'm responsible but i'm not there's a
grand design so if i sin that was what
god wanted right now i don't want to
alienate people who are religious i've
got all kinds of
people who are religious who i love and
respect
with that said i think that this idea of
heaven that we were talking about before
is so self-serving it's like i'll be
like i'll i'll be good so that i can get
into heaven you know and like there's a
reason for your for your uh compassion
because you're like well right i i get
something exactly it's very uh it's very
and it's like and then the question is
then
is that righteous well is it is it if
good things are coming from
an act that is not 100 righteous right
is it
right is it good is it going to be
righteous exactly if you're like going
like well i'm doing this i'm being nice
i'm feeding you i'm clothing you
but i'm doing it not because like yeah
because you want to go to heaven because
i want to go to heaven but it's
benefiting you you're [ __ ] getting
fed you're getting clad i think the
intention is important and like what do
they say it's like the something is its
own
yeah yeah yeah
yeah virtue isn't its own reward there
it is you're doing it because right it's
the right thing to do not because you're
like well somebody's going to pat me
right now i saw a comment on a youtube
video that i put up and it said
something about like oh you're doing you
know doing everything wrong it's not too
like like jesus can see you really need
jesus to save you and like it just kind
of got under my skin a little bit and i
actually responded which i i rarely ever
do and i wrote back i said i said you
know you're right
i'm doing everything wrong but i'm just
gonna keep doing everything wrong and i
plan on letting jesus save me later you
know like uh that's a good thing about
jesus it'll come the last minute jesus
is cool like that on your deathbed the
last thing you think is like let me
like i accept jesus as my savior and
you're good that washes away everything
i said and i even said that like between
you know i'm gonna accept jesus and like
so that he can wipe away all the bad
stuff i do between now and then
and the idea that that holds water it
just makes me so mad and that's why i
love the life review thing because
it's not a the life review you're not
being punished
for for the bad things you did when you
experience the the harm that you caused
others you're not being rewarded for the
joy that you brought people you're just
experiencing it
as it was it's not a punishment it's not
a reward it is just simply the immutable
laws of
of the universe the law of cause and
effect you you experience
the
the
you reap what you sowed you know like
it's just not good or bad it's just that
which is
and that's very very like big in the
cosmos you know like it's not we
we assign good and bad but in reality
there is no good and bad there's just
simply the law of cause and effect
i am if somebody had told me the best
conversation you're going to have about
the afterlife is going to be with stevo
one day
yeah i would have been like i'm sorry
are we in heaven when this happens are
we in the afterlife
he's playing a harp in the clouds
exactly yeah did i die during a jackass
thing am i on jackass how does this all
happen well it's interesting because
most
religious people that die and come back
they come back
and they ask me if they're religious
like oh god no i would never they leave
it behind they leave it behind like i
did that once i did that and they're
like i realize there's no judgmental god
there's just love
you know
i like that there's more of that less of
everything else yeah because there's a
lot of people in this world who have a
brand of jesus i wasn't raised with
right now i may not subscribe anymore
but like
[ __ ] i was fed as a child was was
beautiful and righteous and and really
[ __ ]
fueled me for the rest of my life i
don't do things because of god in heaven
anymore i just do them because it's the
right thing to do and that a lot of that
came from
that forced morality of like you know
hey man there's right and there's wrong
and blah blah blah but more of it came
from not so much the church and religion
but comic books that was where i got a
moral barometer from where it was like
well [ __ ]
do the right thing like yes you could
you get ahead with the bad thing
but
ultimately these [ __ ] always lose and
[ __ ] good always ultimately triumphs
it is a long
was it the moral arc of the universe is
long and bends toward justice yeah do
unto others
that's literally how i was raised i was
raised with the the golden rule and [ __ ]
like do under others as you would have
them do unto you and also my parents
were very like patriotic but not in that
like america [ __ ] yeah
they just really believed in like life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
pursuit of happiness was key for these
[ __ ] you know they my old man worked
like at the post office at night we were
so glad he never went postal and [ __ ]
killed anybody and my mother like didn't
work but you know we struggled we were
like a poor family and [ __ ] like that
but
there was there was no
like sense of like well
we'll suffer now because jesus will take
care of us later no it was just
be good to people and not because it's
going to get you anything it's just
because
that's what you want it's very simple in
life like just proceed with others as
you would have them [ __ ] proceed with
you comment in the youtube section as
you would want somebody to comment to
you exactly yeah even that is
what we can arrive at though is that
it's not about like what i like when
we're computers but then the drive goes
down like here's the thing about that
here's the thing about that that
computer when the drive shuts down
[ __ ] information still on that
computer it's just that one
machine it's done so where does that
information go you think well
i have this zany
theory that i think i i really love it
we had considering i for was raised in
the catholic church
no theory is is off limits or zany my
favorite podcast that we ever did on
this
in in this van was on zoom with a
comedian named duncan trussell
and and we had this this really fun
conversation about my zany theory where
um
the body
right which uh
i i said i think that and i really do
believe this i think that people are
wrong
in assuming that the brain is a
transmitter of consciousness that we
have this idea that the brain is
creating the consciousness the thought
in the mind where
where in in that view
when the body
dies when then then the the
consciousness dies with it because of
course the brain is creating the
consciousness i said
picture it as a radio right now like a
picture
like that the consciousness is
the signal and our body is just simply
the receiver you know and so you could
take a sledgehammer you can smash a
radio
to to smithereens and yeah you've you've
effectively destroyed that radio but
you've not done anything to the signal
and so the signal is i would like to
subscribe to your religion
soon i think these thoughts are right in
line with mine and and duncan trussell
he really found that a bit delicious he
said man you know there's some people
walking around there they think they're
the [ __ ] beatles yeah they're just
that's hysterical that's funny it is
your radio playing the beatles you know
and so so then who are we transmitting
i mean i made that
yeah and and what we shape it into
personality and to add all the things
that make it
uniquely ours so love is universal
and
when we're transmitting it or we're here
to spread love joy whatever the [ __ ] we
have to
shape it
through how we can deliver it we don't
deliver it the way that others i think
everybody has a different soul yeah i
think it's a soul thing and some people
believe in souls some people don't but i
think about everybody everybody's unique
yeah we don't have to do anything it
comes back to
the idea that there is no good there is
no bad there's just
there just is and this experience is
exactly that we are an exercise in god
experiencing itself because without
creation god can have no experience god
doesn't want to be alone god doesn't
want to be lonely so there's also
something about how like you know i'm
not
that educated but like cell division is
the beginning of life right yeah and so
in this theory where god divides divides
it mirrors
yeah the very creation of life itself
that's that's good i i like that too i'm
telling you you can [ __ ] build a
faith on this [ __ ] you make a lot of
money
nobody's got the answer man so you just
give them something that sounds good
they're like [ __ ] yeah that cell
division comment gave me goosebumps too
because like there's a way of viewing it
that like we we are individually cells
in the ultimate organism of
god of the universe yes and the sound do
you think the cell
well i mean
if the cell has any sort of
consciousness
do you think
a single cell in the body is like the
yeah what are the [ __ ] beetles do you
think that cell thinks it's running all
of this
and
is that cell
is that cell wrong is it truly running
all this in collection with everything
else everybody doing their little bit i
think that that to the extent that we
are all one there is every everything
is divine so yeah the cell's the beatles
because there's divinity in [ __ ] and
everything and when you take this view
we're all eyes in the same head we're
all just a piece of the same [ __ ]
divine
loving god
like just this one we're all just like a
a component in the experience of this
beautiful universe then
you've obliterated the idea of hate
of of uh
anything negative because it's like dude
you're you're every bit as much god as i
am
you know like how can you
be demeaning or hateful to to
why would you want to be yeah why would
you want to be and then with the life
review
like that's when the illusion goes away
and you realize oh [ __ ] like
it was just all one [ __ ] thing and
now now i'm experiencing it as one thing
that's how you go through the review and
experience every influence that you had
and that's why i thought i was in a good
spot when i was doing the 12-step
program was because
when you do the night step and make
things right i was like [ __ ] man like i
get to do that now consciously right you
know like i and i went back and made a
lot of things right as if like because
i've done it a couple times and then
the first time i didn't know about life
reviews the second time i did but the
second time i did um you know you you
you go through and you're like
it just helps you kind of figure out you
know
like [ __ ] i really made that person feel
like [ __ ] right you know
i got to make that right immediately
right there's a a [ __ ] wall hanging a
decoration that's been in our house
since we moved in we moved in since you
bought it ben affleck this was ben
we're parked in front of ben affleck's
old house
it would have creeped him out no end but
yeah i bought affleck's house years ago
and we still even though he lived in it
for like a year and i've lived in for 20
we still call it ben's house like oh i
live in ben's house um
in uh in ben's house uh my wife has uh
like decorated over the years uh
it's really beautiful it's like all the
walls it's not like you know [ __ ]
clarkson jay and salam bob it's all
about our family and history and stuff
like that but um
there was this wall hanging you know she
was into yoga for a while there's this
wall hanging that like hung in our house
forever and i would see it all the time
it was by a
a place where i come out the door so
it's like you can't
avoid this see it every day and so
you know i've seen it and i didn't
cognize it one day i was standing there
waiting for something and i was reading
it and it finally sunk in it's very very
simple
and it says may you realize your
divinity in this lifetime
and
it kind of crystallized in that moment
where i was like oh
yes
and and i have and that doesn't mean
like you think you're a god it means
like what you just said like we are all
many eyes in the same head we're all
you know cells in one giant [ __ ]
organism and stuff
and realizing
that you come from the divine and i'm
not saying like god and jesus or
whatever [ __ ] but something
divine i mean step back and call the
world what you will but you have to
admire the intricacy you know it's it is
divine life is divine i mean
put put it this way when the cell in
your dart cells
you know
uh
regenerate die die
like you know that the think of it that
way when we die is there nothing left is
there nothing left for the the cell in
your body that dies in israel you know
what in one sense yeah that cell yeah
but what is that cell
it's
the bigger if we take it right back to
the beginning it's god trying to
understand right trying to relate not
even understand experience experience
that's it there's no such thing as
learning there's only remembering and uh
say it again
there's nothing to learn there's there's
nothing to learn there's remembering
that's a big goodbye that's pretty good
yeah yeah yeah you know i was a brain
burger for a second i was like well what
you're right yeah the only thing that
you have to do
people are always looking for the answer
to life and i'm not saying i know it i'm
just
saying what you know the sum of the
substance of conversations
with god is is like
your whole role is just to experience
life
in all
facets of it that's the gift ramadas
will say that alan watts will say i mean
all these people that
come and just say
enjoy
and and and
i like that i think
our scott and i's view of the universe
is is uh
is really based on this book that we
both
just
that resonated so much with both of us
which is conversations with god
uh neil donald walsh
it started as a trilogy there's been
many books since then
and uh
scott and i flew
to chicago for no reason whatsoever but
to attend a conference where neil donald
walsh was a speaker wow we were like the
only boys yeah
and it just so happened that um that
there was a ufc pay-per-view event in
chicago that night right and and we we
loved the ufc too right so i got to ask
neil donald walsh like
uh what he thought about i said um in in
your book
uh the the third book in the trilogy you
talk a lot about highly evolved beings
and and and the idea the notion of sport
uh being based on the idea that one
uh team or participant uh wins and the
other loses that like that that would
kind of go against any highly evolved uh
you know concept that you would one
would benefit at the expense of another
so does that mean i can't enjoy sports
and he said oh dude you're overthinking
it man i mean come on dude like sports
sports is great you know i said okay
well now let me take it one more the
sports is okay but we're going from here
to go watch
people try to harm themselves as much as
humanly possible in a locked cage at a
huge ultimate fighting event is that
wrong
he said i wouldn't personally choose to
do that that's not doesn't sound like my
thing but i got to believe that there's
some some art to it some skill to it
some you know he says he says i say go
and have a
time [ __ ] man
i
great
permissive but not permissive in the way
of like
do bad things just like you know
go easy on yourself yeah go he's like
yeah you have to
you're in the distraction business
thank you you need to be distracted from
time to time as well the distractor
needs to be distracted the chef has to
eat too and what does the chef eat
before the chef prepares food for others
yeah that's such a beautiful thing to
end on because we i wanted to
you you said it and and i
formally
uh identify as this like i you know i do
i do all this dumb stuff i hurt myself i
did think you know
when you were going like these [ __ ]
locked themselves in a cage and they're
trying to hurt themselves not that far
removed
from what you've done as well
right but uh you know you could say that
like i i i break bones i shove things up
my butt like i'm the lowest brow form of
entertainer that you could possibly
imagine and and one one might jump to
the conclusion that that makes me
a kind of a low level like you know and
and i just don't see it that way i i
think
like my view on it i identify first as
an attention [ __ ]
and then i i i really say like that's
the reality but
i consider the
in this experience like what you
described as your mom thinking all of
the hooks that were in all the weight
all the stress everything that attended
just felt lighter suddenly she's like
i'm free i'm off the hook from all that
[ __ ] and not that she wasn't saying my
life is bad is terrible but even the
minor pressures of like i gotta take the
garbage out
all that [ __ ] is gone she's like i don't
have to do
a [ __ ] thing
she felt lighter in there right and so
there are there is all that attendant
weight and stress and and hooks in the
human experience and
i think that that
most people i think you could probably
say the majority of people don't
genuinely enjoy their job i agree you
know like they they don't
raised by a man who every night he
worked at the post office did the night
shift and
[ __ ] was undone every night like
desperate not to go
like a man who's being walked to the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] gallows or something like he was
just like oh god i can't right and so
over a lifetime you're like
on a job look what it does i'll take a
shot doing some weird [ __ ] yeah most
people don't enjoy their [ __ ] job a
lot of people aren't happy in their
marriages some people are physically
like uh you know
suffering you know like like there's a
lot a lot of people
don't [ __ ] enjoy their day and and
my
goal as an attention [ __ ] is is to
create
some
compelling
[ __ ]
thing to witness
that serves as a distraction from that
and and and i actually formally gave
myself the title of a distraction
therapist that's absolutely right it's a
beautiful way of putting what we do for
a living right and now now i don't i'm
not gonna be so arrogant as to say that
like i can
fix any i'm not fixing any problems i i
respect your problems enough to know
that they're not going away
i'm not gonna [ __ ] improve your
situation i'm just going to to in the
moment in them if i'm doing my job right
i've entertained you enough that i have
made your problems
disappear temporarily because you're not
thinking about them and that's a big
[ __ ] noble thing put it this way
who's the most important person in a
kingdom
the king no the fool
because if the fool don't [ __ ] make
the king laugh the king's a real [ __ ]
and everybody gets dead
so at the end of the day the distraction
that's what makes life livable for a lot
of [ __ ] people and stuff i'm gonna
tell you a story before we get out of
here that just as we were sitting there
going like oh my god i i owe you
so uh i got this new clerks movie coming
out yeah uh we're touring it uh you can
come see it with me or you can see it uh
it opens september 13th
uh this clerk's three
dot movie is where you can find tickets
and information in any event i tell you
that just to remind folks that i from
time to time i make movies um that means
i've always made movies that tend toward
the what's the term for your universe
universe the ones that are connected the
view of skuniverse my production company
was called view askew so like back in 94
we were like this is the view universe
so i have gone up in front of the mpaa
a few times the mpaa is the motion
picture association of america and
they're the folks who are responsible
for rating a movie so you know
r [ __ ] nc 17g that's their [ __ ]
job um traditionally i've made movies
that are very frank and colorful with
the language and [ __ ] like that and
obsessed with reverend very irreverent
as they say so
there have been r's pretty much across
the board but periodically i've been
handed an nc-17 the first time was on
clerks clerks is a movie with no nudity
and no violence whatsoever just for all
that conversation the mpa was like this
is not suitable for children
understanding would you not uh revise it
and then resubmit it until you got it
done that's a process well you can do
that and that's part of the story so
i have gone in front of the mpa uh four
times to
argue
a rating down because you have two
choices you could do the cuts that
they're suggesting
um to get to the rating that you want or
you can arbitrate it and when you
arbitrate it you go into like what feels
like a court setting um you uh they show
the movie to an audience made up a jury
if you will of members of nato which
you're like holy [ __ ] but it just means
the national association of theater
owners so these are the people yes
you're like what the [ __ ]
theater owners so people who basically
if you own a movie theater you're the
last line of defense and so they're the
best judge
because they're the people who have to
deal with people who are like
i paid five dollars to watch this movie
and these people are cursing their
[ __ ] full heads off and blah blah
blah they deal with the public so they
have a better idea of what the public
says
make more money if more people are
allowed in yes
so so you basically show the movie to
the to the nato crowd it's like six
people and then you do a kangaroo court
of sorts the mpaa person gets up to say
this is why we think this movie is this
rating and you know we stand by it and
then you're allowed to get up as the
filmmaker and say
why you don't think that's the case so
i've done that on clerks
i did it on jersey girl
i did it on
zack and miri
and each time
you have something to do with it and
i'll tell you how that is so
so those three movies alone like i went
in front of the mpaa and flipped it each
time jay and silent bob strike back we
didn't go to arbitration but like uh
that too i argued at one point i was
like we could totally keep this
so i had a good record for beating the
mpaa
um
the third time i went for zach and mary
like uh at one point that we made a
movie called yoga hosers which was a kid
movie kids movie and they gave it an r
and i said well i'm gonna i'm gonna
arbitrate and instantly like we're just
gonna flip it you're fine you're pg-13
we don't want to go through this with
you again um so on the third one which
was zach and miri they gave us an nc-17
for a sequence in the movie where jeff
anderson is playing deacon the cameraman
and he's shooting uh jason muse uh who's
playing lester
um [ __ ] uh stacy um who was played by
katie morgan and he's in the scene he's
[ __ ] her in the ass and and jeff
anderson is below with a camera shooting
the whole thing this is predicated on a
story i once heard that really happened
to barry sonnenfell barry sonfeld the
director of adam's family many things he
was a dp for years uh a dp's director of
photography uh he was shooting somebody
uh having anal sex for porn early in his
career and the person pulled out and he
was [ __ ] sprayed with [ __ ] and so he
was like i'll never do a porn again so
somebody told me that on a commercial
set i was like i'm [ __ ] totally using
that story so in our scene
uh jeff's character is shooting this
anal scene and then something happens
and jay turns very shocked and and pops
out you don't see that part but you hear
it but what you see is a visual of jeff
anderson getting [ __ ] sprayed with
[ __ ]
yes oh beyond speckled this is just a
[ __ ] pudding got dumped on his face
shot is
two seconds and change two seconds and
maybe 14 [ __ ] frames of the [ __ ] on
the face so naturally the mpa was just
like never in a million years you can't
[ __ ] do this so
i got to arbitrate and when i went up to
arbitrate
so ladies and gentlemen we all agree
that the fake fecal matter that wound up
on my actor's face
is a product of movie magic that's not
[ __ ] that's we mix ups oatmeal and some
[ __ ] coloring and [ __ ] like that
so if we all agree that
then we know that like we're in the
unreality business i was like there's a
motion picture just came out fairly
recently
it's called jackass emotion picture and
in jackass they wear a fart helmet where
at one point somebody farts so [ __ ]
hard that fecal matter sprays into a
living human being's [ __ ] face and
this is not fiction this literally
happened ladies and gentlemen that movie
is rated r
if that's real
and you let it go how can you [ __ ]
stop fake poop
and they flipped it so because of you
guys you're lucky i wasn't there
because nothing made it into that mask
that's just the power of my imagination
is that really good the idea that
something was gross was just always your
performance was so strong
that it made the mpa go like well right
is right wow that's really fantastic i
was thinking as we were talking i was
like oh my god i forgot like that's a
big part of my mythology it's just like
me standing there it was it was my uh
that's a great case you built you know
ladies and gentlemen i submit the part
helmet
it was a real law order for the third
act moment so great and and what's even
greater is uh
the artistic integrity and not just
cutting the scene you're like no man my
art
again i had a justification where i'm
like this their movie is essentially a
documentary like
you guys are doing real [ __ ] things
and maybe there's a heightened error of
like hey we know there are cameras here
but it's real i'm like if they can
really do that why can't we fake do it
now i'm really glad to know that there
was no [ __ ] [ __ ]
i would have weakened my argument there
would have been like there is no [ __ ] in
that film mr smith i've been like oh i
see your argument would have been really
really good um if you had uh our third
jackass maybe with me getting launched
up in the porta potty i was covered in
[ __ ]
yeah what now in that moment do you have
the presence of mind to keep your mouth
closed or no i didn't know oh my god oh
my god
oh my god i mean there's commitment to
your art form and then there's [ __ ] in
the mouth steve jesus i know yeah it was
dog [ __ ] because osho won't let you get
covered in human [ __ ] they've been yeah
that's a [ __ ] that's that's a good
good to know it's an inside
company i don't know if the company
still exists but a company in los
angeles county somewhere
that will sell you as much dog [ __ ] as
you care to purchase and the name of the
company was
or is i don't know
we do do do that's genius
oh my god that's fantastic no idea what
their clientele is
beyond you guys
how much do you pay for [ __ ] like a
hundred dollars a pound like what i i
don't know i don't know but on this on
the fourth movie i won't go above 5 000
on the fourth movie they uh they
was it
13
gallons 15 gallons of pig semen
i mean that's a lot of happy pigs yeah
what do you need pig semen for other
than make pigs
rather than us it was it wasn't a
company that did pick semen it was like
they didn't they don't do we do
yeah for sure um
it wasn't they they found a pig farm
with the guys willing and they
interviewed the guys about how much
they're spending all their days
just jacking off pigs for you guys for
us yeah and it wasn't something that
they normally did
i had to say the least yeah
pigs just happen to
have the most volume
per load is that right they're just like
arcing ropes of gizmos not even robes
like pints
could you imagine those who is a bigger
fan of jackass than those pigs right
now they got to get jacked off for weeks
oh my god like are you guys making
another movie soon
yeah so so uh so you're doing a tour
with clerks three yeah
we did it with reboot uh james reboot
and stuff we've done it with a few of
the flicks you know i try to
exist in the business still in a
business that doesn't care about me or
want me and [ __ ] like that and so i i
found the nooks and crannies to be able
to kind of do what i does that mean that
the film only
uh plays
where you physically are for the first
run for the tour generally speaking yes
but we also have for people who are like
i can't [ __ ] be in detroit to see
your movie on one night or [ __ ] and i
don't want to pay a hundred dollars to
do so or whatever the [ __ ] um we also
put it out through fathom events which
just goes into normal ass movie theaters
right so it's supposed to be like
screenings on september 13th and 15th
but everyone bought so many advanced
tickets that fathom was like we're going
to extend it for like a week so we're
going to get a friday and saturday which
is kind of cool so people can see it
that way just at a normal ass theater or
they can go to like a theater theater
and watch it with me and then we q a
afterwards i watched the trailer and i i
i loved the the
c-3po and r2
oh yeah
it's very the whole movie is very
informed by that heart attack i gave my
heart attack to one of my characters and
you know my unlike my unlike me my
characters like still work at that store
that i used to work at um but my life
changed because i was like i'm gonna
make a movie about working in the store
and so that's what clerks three is
randall survives a heart attack he's
like [ __ ] i've watched movies my
whole life never once thought about
doing this [ __ ] i'm gonna make a
movie and he makes a movie about working
in the convenience store so essentially
they make clerks the movie that we all
know
so it's fun because it allows you to get
meta as [ __ ] the snake doesn't just eat
its tail it jerks itself off into its
mouth like a pig for a [ __ ] jacket
um but it's uh it's it's good it's funny
it's [ __ ] beautiful like in the
conversations we've just had
about life and uh what happens after um
this is a movie i think you'll both dig
for that very reason based on the
conversation back before i got in this
van i'd be like maybe they'll see it one
day after i leave this van i'm like oh
you'll dig it it's about the very things
we've been talking about i love it man i
love it i love it and and wow this is uh
we might have set a record for the
longest we've gone on a podcast is that
right i love it yeah i love the sound of
my own voice that was inevitable
it's been uh well i have an hour and 34
on here yeah
look at that 90 minutes man they could
have watched clubs three how long was
your movie this is 92. we're longer than
clark's three
[ __ ] funny two because dk was uh
asking us hey what do you think about
doing four sponsors on an episode and
i'm like nah dude that's gonna start to
bum out the audience i'm not willing to
do that but on an hour and a half and
now you're stretched now there's some
real estate
yeah dude man thank you so much kevin
appreciate it thanks for having me it's
been great
dude that was awesome it was a good [ __ ]
kids my god and again i didn't have to
walk very far i walked out of my house
you want to do it again tomorrow yeah
let's do it again
yeah dude that genuinely was my new
all-time favorite episode i really think
um
[ __ ] i loved that and you know i love
you for sticking around and as we
approach what is it august 24th
it's uh one month and three days until
my book comes out a hard kick in the
nuts
what i've learned from a lifetime of
terrible decisions i'm really excited
for this book release and uh if you
haven't already pre-ordered the book
please do because that's the only way to
get a signed copy of the hardcover
version when it first comes out that was
my little thing i was like man like i'm
gonna sign the pre-order ones
so please pre-order it because it's
gonna help the book so much if you do
and if you read my first book you know
that that book kicked us and this one's
every bit as crazy so yeah dude um
let's let's pre-order that book i
appreciate you guys thank you so much
man wow this was a killer [ __ ]
episode too huh yeah dude